good
afternoon Millennials welcome to the
morning toast afternoon Edition special
time and a little late too because I got
stuck behind a school bus that crashed
which is so sad
but don't worry everyone's okay how did
you know that oh I didn't but I saw the
crash ended like a fender bender it was
like truly like a like a bump in the ass
and the fact that they took up the whole
street for this little bump in the ass
of a school bus was so annoying it's
like pull over that's so sad but like
school buses are just like this hazard
and you know like all the kids are
freaking and their parents are like
where are the kids
and it's just drama that I'm glad I'm
not a part of yeah I'm glad that
everyone's okay I mean it's like well
you have to tell the parents like there
was a crash and that sounds bad but it's
like who's alive but no it's like we're
all fine we're all just late we're all
fine we're all late Theo is here so I'm
Chuck to my core because I didn't expect
it I was actually gonna go to Theo's
house later that's how much I missed him
so to bring the precious gift to me it's
just a precious gift yeah and I'm just
so tired made it to uh I can't believe I
haven't been home since Coachella like
I'm the person who sat here on whenever
the last time I was here was which was
Thursday and the person I am now like
I'm two different people
how were the Carolinas the Carolinas
were good Greenville South Carolina they
don't know which Carolina you were both
that's why okay I was in South Carolina
first Greenville like the cutest town
ever like one road it was so Bluebell
like Heart of Dixie so precious did
Finch Street yeah we loved it and then
we went to Greensboro would you say that
like the swankiest hotel like they were
playing jazz music like in not even like
outside like where you pull up in the
driveway like me and Murray we're like
swing dancing outside the car it was
hilarious it was all good very good time
I hope everyone had a good time at the
shows it seems as though they did Lauren
was there from cam toast Oh Lauren
Collins yes I've seen her she's also was
in Orlando I met her husband how is he
so like every show I like pick on a guy
and I was picking on this guy and then
they came to me great I'm like I'm and
your husband's Kyle Wow Kyle Collins he
can take it yes
well I'm excited to be here thanks for
shucking and jiving we're just trying
out a new format seeing what the
toasters like cuz you know I am off for
the summer so we are gonna have some
some real steady steady work weeks yeah
I got it summer and you know summer
fridays which we didn't take last year
even though we said we were going to and
i still reserve the right to take a
couple summer fridays yes so
it's gonna be consistent but then I'm
booking the final leg of this tour in
the fall hitting up all the places you I
mean I hit up so I'm trying not to do
like midweek shows cuz like this week
was stupid I missed the whole week for
like three shows so I'm trying to do
like weekends where like maybe I'll miss
a Friday so we're just trying out to
perform at sweet ride the calling an
episode on Tuesday but you everyone
really liked yeah so if it's if it's not
a guest co-host like I think I think
where we're at now it's like if it's not
the most premium guest co-host like
everyone loves like we'll do a call in
or something yeah we'll figure it out
yeah good stuff and the podcast thing is
better for me so I don't have to put
makeup on and today was so nice I got I
mean actually I'm more productive when
we do a morning show cuz I wake up
earlier but I went to the gym
this morning I went to live method I've
worked out I shower I look fantastic
yeah it's like you're more productive it
has pros and cons cuz like when we start
at 10 a.m. and like I'm productive I
have the whole day what should I do
business meeting here lunch in there you
the whole thing but now it's like when I
wake up usually and do the toasts for
the first like 5 or 10 minutes of the
toasts I'm in a terrible mood I'm just
cuz like it's the morning but now it's 3
p.m. and I'm not in the temperament
except that school bus crash like did
put me I'm off you know like my middle
ear like is off but yeah but you have
ticks
so that puts you in a good mood and he's
looking so fresh and so cute I run into
my house like and after not being here
for a week and like we just reunited and
I love having the I have a dog camera
now and I love it for a million reasons
but I get to rewatch my reunions with
Theo because it catches it on camera
precious angel men it's really cute if
we do say so ourselves Theo right what
does he hide everyone come come say hi
to everyone deserves a precious gift
like the one that has been delivered to
us he's just like feeling he's feeling
really excited like everything's back
back to normal you know cuz he was
separated from me for a while
FOMO that he wasn't at Coachella know
Theo knows better than to ever have FOMO
cuz Coachella is just not for Theo you
know yeah it's not puppy chela he's too
you know confident in who he is to have
to you know think Coachella is the type
of place for him if that makes sense
what about stagecoach stagecoach is
definitely Tiggy vibes
I wouldn't literally die to bring him
good no I mean we could but we're gonna
meet the festival for so many hours and
I'm not bringing him to the festival
when I see people who bring their dogs
to festivals it's so sad yeah that's
like it's hot out there and he's not a
desert dog no he's like a New York City
rat he's actually a Texas boy but filter
still not the desert yeah there's
nothing quite like the desert and we
know because we experienced it firsthand
this week we did and we're and we're
gonna experience it again because we
just love that sort of self-sabotage
except I'm so excited for stagecoach
like every day I just can't stop
thinking about it I just buy more things
for a stagecoach and I still have
nothing to worry I'm like I keep
spending money so like I got a car I got
a house I got clothes I got to get my
chicken it's like I can't stop spending
money on festival season it's truly
expense I can't stop spending money the
government came for my baby no Jackie I
have seriously the amount of money I
have in my checking account right now
because you don't understand we're
freelancers so when regular people get
paid it's nice the government takes it
out and like it sucks in that boy or it
takes it out of your paycheck
but because we're freelancers and we're
self-employed every money we get we get
untaxed so at the end of the year we pay
one lump sum and I have to say the
amount of money I have in my checking
account right now I haven't had this law
of a balance like since college like
since I was truly like out here like
Hungary like missing meals no I'm so
should it couldn't have come in the
worst time like it's festival season no
no and I'm like usually especially when
I travel with Margo like I'm so frugal
like if we go to this bomb like my god
whatever you want it's on me but
literally I was like you are on your own
[ __ ] I have no money for myself let
alone you know totally and thank God we
got Thursday boots Oh totally I'm
wearing mine right now I'm wearing mine
oh they're so cute you know these days
I'm really relying on the free product
we get from tow sponsors because I don't
have anything else I mean I love his
boots for one thousand reasons one
because like this is this is the exact
type of boot I wear just like a nice
chunky heel so it's not too
uncomfortable and black these are the
Paloma boot but my favorite part about
there's a boot is that pick up the leg a
little I guess you could say I'm a
produce the stage but I want them to get
dusty shoes um they were the company was
founded like with the premise that all
shoes should be comfortable and you know
what like I totally agree I totally
agree with that and I like I was so
excited I need I always need new boots I
need a new stage which boots I love my
Thursday boots because you can love
yours too because Thursday boots
believes in year-round honest prices so
while they don't do sales or discounts
they're giving our listeners free
two-day shipping on their first order
and always offer free returns and
exchanges so you have nothing to lose
trying out a few pairs go to Thursday
boots calm saj toast and you can
hair on the doorstep before next
Thursday that's th urs da y bo OTS comm
/ toast for free today shipping returns
and exchanges in the words of Thursday
boots in the Moors of all I can't you
deserve more comfortable
wait that's written by the way do you
know why they call it Thursday boots no
because on Thursday like you work hard
but like you have something coming it's
that way yeah and how do you know this
dude right read the notes
I didn't read our writing I love a bread
with a message behind the name you know
I love a brand with an oak free quality
product for us yeah me too oh my god I
just love the thing that I needed to buy
for myself that I no longer can afford
and these are the type of types of boots
that I get like once a season because I
wear them the entire winter like two
clubs in the snow and then I need a new
pair every season so these are writing a
pair of I'm really happy with them I'm
excited for you
are you ready for the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast I ready for the past five -
honestly I don't know yes I am hello
Brian I'm sorry did she explain where
there's an end in her user her middle
name is n so it's Rachel and O'Brien and
now it's Rachel nobody I thought it was
just comedy you two but no it's that's
her name how was it it was good did she
give any event of her pearls cause she
actually did okay so cuz she's just like
they're her friends if she was just
talking about them like friends like not
realizing that we're hanging on her
every word and by the way Before we jump
in did you do the Billy Lee story like
all the drama no because I'm not caught
up oh okay and because I've all I'm
watching his Game of Thrones so unless
you want to talk to me about a game of
Thrones don't talk to me okay understood
I just made it to season five nothing on
TV will ever be as interesting like
puppy game pales in comparison to be
under the battle of Esther's it's a
[ __ ] battle of the bastard totally
battle of the Blackwater oh my god I
can't stop talking in like a game of
Thrones accent like especially when it
says the word brother but brother they
all say like a brother
note like any time like I feel like I'm
always just getting advice in life but
now I give Game of Thrones advice a lion
doesn't concern themselves with the
opinions of sheep we try to answer your
previous question yes I am ready oh you
are well now I'm not oh wait what was
the ritual O'Brien - oh so she said that
at the reunion of her
is really crazy which means weird
because the seasons not and everyone's
getting along so she said that Kristen
Katie and Stassi like excited a little
bit at the Reunion oh we were talking
about how creepy it is that Lisa is so
obsessed with Kristen like a crazy ex
girl yeah just works her into every
conversation oh he's talking about her
always putting her down
and apparently Lisa comes for Krishna
three Union like in a totally like off
the cuff like random unnecessary way and
it's like shocking and Kristen is so
shocked and everyone is shocked like her
weirdness comes to fruition
you know up like as much as that's
annoying like it's about time this
Advanta prompt started like carrying her
weight in the show she's the most boring
part of it so she's doing something no
she can go home the Mad King burn them
all
so yes I'm sorry I'm ready to deliver
okay so I'm ready this is the first
story I want to read the headline that's
given to me by NBC News and then I want
to tell you the actual headline also NBC
News
Lorri Lachlan's daughters Instagram
account off-site Instagram declined to
say whether Isabella Jie a newly had
removed the page herself or if the
platform had taken it down so the story
is that Isabella Jie a newly no longer
has an Instagram account there is no way
on God's green diddly dally earth that
Instagram deleted her page NBC News or
Kelly still has a page let's say dumbest
thing everyone still has a page just cuz
her mom is on trying LV has an Instagram
I can't this is the dumbest thing I've
ever read and like you think it's NBC
right yes did you expect more like that
they would know the way that Instagram
works no she deleted her account which
is exciting for Bella Hadid because now
she can get at Bella something happy for
her there's no I think if she
deactivated it she stills a username in
like 30 days nothing more it's like six
months really yeah I think we'll see on
Twitter it's a year that is the lousiest
thing ever like yeah the people that
Instagram are out here taking down the
Instagram page of a child
Isabel genuinely because her mom frauded
college administrators but not but not
Olivia Jade allegedly but not Olivia
tape well speaking of the Olivia jade
scandal
I made it onto the e-news Instagram last
night like not in the way that I wanted
to you know what I mean
so I did I told you guys when I was in
LA three weeks ago I did a really like
nice fun interview with Justin the lady
sitter who filled in for me here and we
did like he does a a similar format it's
like I bury inside the Actor's Studio
vibe
called just the sip where we just talk
deep but we were talking a lot about
council culture as someone who was
momentarily cancelled I feel like I
offered good insight
I'm spoke a lot about what it was like
to be canceled and then he went through
a list of people who are like on the
brink of being cancelled and he was
asked me whether I think they deserve to
or not so it was obvious ones like are
Kelly yes Jordan Woods no but like when
they said the Olivier Jay Olivia Jade
one like I I think I'm unique in my
opinions of Olivia Jade and I know the
world was pretty much turned on her but
like I know her and I think she's a good
person so I just like said what I
thought and in promoting that interview
I did with Justin enews took it upon
themselves to take a clip from the
interview and put it on their Instagram
which has what 10 million followers yeah
and they literally chuck it was a 20
minute interview they took 10 seconds
and he actually took the worst ten
because it was such a good funny
interview or saw that that Instagram
post said they did teasing the episode I
got a pit and I was like oh my god I'm
so of course they only dare to watch the
episode they only included the part
where I said that
Olivia J doesn't deserve to be canceled
and everyone the comments deserted me
and it was just brutal right then I
watched the episode and I don't know how
long it is 20 minutes of pure premium
content you think you know I was I
didn't want it to end
I was literally smiling from ear to ear
obviously we talk every day like we work
together we have the same like pretty
much opinions opinions life experience
etc but I would I feel like I was
watching someone that I was learning
from oh my no it was really well done
and it was so tired like I was not
having it that day but I think like I
was wearing a pajama sweater like you
were just being yourself and thank you
it was really enjoyable you were being
funny and and relatable and humble thank
you yeah he's just Alerus yeah I love
Justin he's very like he's a great
interviewer you know because he's funny
and like offers good like rebuttals but
he doesn't make it about himself which
is hard for me that I interview people
and all I want to do is talk about
myself yeah you know you're really gonna
enjoy being the interviewee I much more
prefer to be talent than the host you
know that's why people like when I was
growing up they're like you didn't have
any talk show and I was like yeah I'm
Oprah and then you realize like Oprah
doesn't talk Oprah listens and that's
where they lost me yeah I understand
yeah okay well anyways Isabella Jia Yu
Lee has definitely probably deleted her
own Instagram account um you know this
is not even a question yeah this isn't a
question I'm the coach
here's why why not a little Yugi are
they getting different legal counsel why
no why this sperm that's the only
question to ask you're not who done it
no so stupid oh my that's like hilarious
that's so funny like I would never
notice that because I truly like when I
read the news like I solely read the
headline so you have to read like the
first paragraph to understand how stupid
this article is and I would never get to
that point because I don't read articles
just headlines I just I was Chuck I was
Chuck and I just wanted to bring it to
the forefront you know because I never
started my segment of had lines that are
laughable but um oh you should we should
but it's like a lot on my plate
yeah oh you're so busy being an
entrepreneur I'm so busy so anyways yeah
we'll keep you posted on what goes down
with the genie Lisa's the sister is Gina
Lee
yeah I love that sisters are my brothers
Osborne sisters she a new Lee brothers
Osborne are gonna be at stagecoach
alright yeah maybe I mean that uh no
they're not you're not no are you sure a
hundred percent well they're coming at
mystery next month oh oh I mean tickets
oh I'm not there why is that with Old
Dominion yeah J hereness yeah it will
give minion and Mitchell turn penny
which I really wanted to go to but I'm
gonna be in Israel
woo oh well then you're gonna miss mom
toast yeah I know but Mars was like in
love with him so I could take my spot
okay fair and she's taking my ticket too
maybe he'll wear a hat and show me mrs.
hat again
ya know but I think he actually has a
girlfriend very sad oh I'm so excited
for stagecoach I go to Coachella this
weekend just made me realize like
imagine Coachella with our families and
good music like when we were sitting
there like trying to make fetch happen
with Taemin Paola
right now I we were trying to go on
Jason Aldean like I'd be living I have
just been making so many plans like I've
been talking my shell Randolf because
Ben's coming and we're staying in a
community that lets golf and Ben like
Zach Shapiro and Zach winery but don't
really golf so I texted Michelle was
like just Greg golf like trying to get
Ben and Greg to be best friends so like
I could just like submit my friendship
with Michelle so just like stay tuned if
Ben plays golf and they said Colton
gulps - so like just everyone say about
saying okay hey I got to and we just got
to get Lauren Elizabeth there I need it
and put it out there I'm in need of some
extra passes because I just like keep
inviting everyone to stagecoach
so if you work for girls and boys like
hit me up I need like five artist passes
okay
have a few already but I need more and
I'm just like using every connect I have
because I'm trying to make this weekend
like my weekend like and we'll work for
it well work for it like I'll do it
everyone I just need the passes okay
sorry I'm just I'm thirsting out golden
voice stagecoach I know you need
everyone from the [ __ ] bad surpasses
even that girl who's never been kissed
who like was on screen for five minutes
like please okay she seems nice yeah
okay next story a little more Liberty
legal news Joe Giudice see deportation
appeal denied with my ice as final
decision still looms Joe Giudice
continues to wait to learn his fate a
source close though is a confirm that I
see II is pronounced ice yeah cuz like
it's FBI Fibby or the CIA Co no I think
it's confirmed that it's pronounced ice
okay I don't know that I think quote I'm
just telling falsities today so I'm
welcome to the morning falls afternoon
Oh Church Archer quote the Board of
Immigration I do I started one more
thing whenever I like there's nothing
else to say I realize I say true George
oh well I feel like he goes in waves I
feel like at one point I used to be like
totally okay but I was just about to say
for sure for sure but also when I was
just about to say it's like if you ever
want to know if I'm not listening or not
I will say totally I don't listen when
people murder is talking on the plane I
was like totally well she's just chatty
she doesn't shut the [ __ ] up we recently
come to the realization that Margo
doesn't shut up she's so chatty if
you're I didn't know that if you're in a
long car ride with her one on one
praying okay like a month ago me and my
girl we're driving from Clearwater to
Orlando in the middle of the night I
like to drive after the shows cuz
there's no traffic so it's like it's
tired like it was a three-hour drive for
the first two hours we chatted you know
but you know when when you're in a car
ride back the conversation eventually
just like fades out and we're like 10
minutes from the hotel like the car ride
was so long I just couldn't get into the
hotel fast enough and this [ __ ] is like
still talking about stuff and I was like
I didn't even realize she was talking so
much until I realize I didn't said
anything in like 20 minutes that's a big
long time for you and I said to Margo I
was like can you shut the [ __ ] up like
and she was like what and I was like I
never realized like you talk so much and
she was freaking out she was like Jackie
just said that to me and I was like I
hadn't known I didn't speak to you about
it but I didn't realize until like we
were just scraping the bottom of the
barrel for conversation it's like we
could have just stopped talking like I
mean we could have gone to
sleep like we could have done anything
in the car like she just wouldn't let
the conversation stop Matt cuz it
happened it's happened twice with me in
her I don't remember the first time it
was like I'm not someone that would ever
call someone out you know she's so cute
and sweet and like four she had to be so
chatty for me to be like [ __ ] you are
Chanti know for me to notice someone
else talking too much as someone who
literally never shuts the [ __ ] up she
was talking so much and not only that at
the most inopportune time like there are
times to be silent and one of those
times is in a long car ride at the end
and then a few weeks ago she and I were
we were sitting we are coming from the
Toso and she co-hosted with me we were
going to pick up the oh I was getting a
migraine we're sitting in the car he
goes in the car and i'm just like i'm
i'm not well bit no it's like you're
done and she is talking a mile a minute
and i was like please Chatty Cathy like
it's just so funny how like I'm 24 I've
had a sister for I've had Margaret's
sister for 21 years and I didn't realize
that she was the most chatty person
until 21 years have done now you
wouldn't expect it apart because she's
actually like super like she's not like
always the friendliest she keeps to
herself a little bit but I think there's
something about her when she gets
someone wanting a car she corners that
yeah I feel like she's gonna get in
group settings she's she's observing
yeah no she's she's absorbing right but
when she's one-on-one man could she talk
no it was like really eye-opening for me
like I was so rude I'm like you have to
show she's texting me immediately she's
like oh my god Chloe just told me I'm
chatty
I guess it's true it's nice to learn new
things about yourself even as a young
adult - Heather Dubrow if people if two
people are saying you're dead like yeah
and that's not the words I've had the
Dubrow that's like the words of
philosophers like Socrates had their
Dubrow popularized it okay I didn't hear
from Heather and I know it maybe you
think you didn't hear from Heather but
you did yeah I know a source close to
you need tells a source close to Joe
tells E News oh yeah the Board of
Immigration Appeals ruled against Joe in
an April 6 decision he unfortunately had
to learn about the Board's decision by
mail since the process is done entirely
by malice Lee well that's rough
according to the insider
the reality star born Giuseppe Giudice
has one final chance to avoid
deportation on Wednesday the legal team
for Joe filed the petition for the
federal court to review of the Appeals
decision however if the federal court
refuses to a remedial appeal the source
says
we got deported we are extremely
disappointed that the Board of
Immigration Appeals has denied mr.
Giudices appeal the family attorneys
James J Leonard jr. stated that attorney
is just like everywhere he's an attorney
he's been here yeah he's an attorney
he's a publicist he's an assistant and a
manager he is the busiest guide with one
client I feel like but you know what
this is really sad but at the same time
I feel like Theresa doesn't care I feel
like she has made these arrangements no
for for worst-case scenario like I feel
like she's prepared and that makes her
less fearful and I think in fact at the
end of the day like she's sad for her
kids but like her life won't change
because even if he stays they're not
together why are you laughing something
commented on the Theo cam Felix's had a
conversation oh man and for those
podcast he has passed the [ __ ] out on
the floor on his back with his eyes
closed
oh well they can meme out of it when
Margo starts going on one of her rats
when you get into car hey I'm gonna when
you get into a car with such expectation
feel the designs cause we all do like in
the pond today in the park yeah okay
that's good I love making content
verbally Lisa Vanderpump
no one Lisa I swear on my children's
life sounds like I just made her into
Brown of the Blackwater Samwell Tarly
the wildling with the tea with the Ryder
Trauma tormund um anyways back to mr. ZJ
mr. Giudice at this point I will be
shocked if he stays me to where it used
to be I would have been shocked if you
were
I used to say people think people were
like putting this in the headlines like
its clickbait and then at the end of the
day it wouldn't actually happen but no
it's real it's very real and I think I
think Teresa is ready is ready for
whatever decision comes her way
yeah it's really sad like for the
children but I feel like for the past
five years they've been in limbo like
what their future will be in like and
even on the show like you know her
husband's in jail so she gets this all
the special treatment but it's like once
the verdict come
down like move up you have to move on
normal yeah and it'll be interesting to
see if she can even go back to just
being treated like a know like a normal
person you know what life is all about
perspective because I'm saying this is
so sad for the children but at the end
of the day now they have a parent who
lives in Italy and like they get to go
to their dad's house in Italy for the
summer like maybe drive an Italian
sports car and like eat pasta maybe like
have a sprint like a summer fling with
Paolo you know right it's like when our
parents got divorced like before daddy
died there was only one year when our
parents got divorced and daddy was
living in Long Island and we had like a
summer house totally he went on the
weekends we had caught a car we went
swimming like no life is what you make
it
so it's all about perspective guys gia
just think of it now you have a house in
Italy a summer house I totally agree
also I could really see gia getting
along with the Italian camper oh she is
the Italian camper she is actually one
of the most stable human beings like in
the world oh I'm sorry
Milania would get along with the Italian
camper that sort of singing I actually
think they might butt heads Milania is
the Italian camper yeah
buongiorno well socks prayers and well
wishes to the Giudice family okay next
story was full of interesting factory oh
my god wait do you know the story Joe
puts the ice in Giudice
that's horrible why it's a wordplay yes
we said worse things our show at the
English language this next story is full
of interesting factoids that I found
unbelievably interesting can you
probably don't know about well that's
the thing about interesting factoids why
I personally am so drunk that miss
they're so interesting Conan O'Brien is
on trial for stealing jokes do you know
this wait what the headline is Patton
Oswalt and Andy Richter expected to
testify in Conan O'Brien strolling joke
trial apparently this has been going on
Patton Oswalt is always at the forefront
of like getting comedic justice I
believe he's defending Conan oh and Andy
Richter oh oh oh I thought it was
opposite okay
when this Conan O'Brien's strolling joke
case goes to trial in San Diago next
month who knew that this was a case
they're just like sliding it in there
right like as if it's comment like roe v
wade right the most popular case it's
like Joe Giudice we've been talking
about three months in like who wrote
this up paid sex for the onion you know
that's what it feels like it feels like
a big story okay continue
I had to double-check it's not April 1st
Oh totally some of his famous friends
are expected to take the stand comedian
Patton Oswalt and O'Brien's on-air
sidekick Andy Richter are both on the
witness list according to The Hollywood
Reporter in July 2016
Alec's case Berg sued the late-night
host his company Conoco TBS and Time
Warner alleging that Conan writers stole
drugs from his social media feed and
vlog about Caitlyn Jenner Tom Brady and
the Washington Monument
while Oswald Richter a Turner production
exec and multiple Conan writers are
expected to appear as witnesses during
the trial a California federal judge
vetoed to comedy experts case Berg hoped
to call on court documents show the
judge also granted O'Brien's request to
close the court during testimony about
confidential financial information the
rest of the trial will be open to the
public the next hearing in the case is
scheduled for May 23rd I had no idea
that you could actually sue for this I
just have such a hard time believing
that like this team of people who's
littering it's just their job to sit
around move up to 30 rock it's your job
to sit around and write jokes are like
trolling some Instagram stealing jokes
from him I don't know I don't think it's
that but I think like they go on it like
they use social media like anyone else
they saw something funny and they took
it for their show I don't think so
or like sometimes you see something you
or you hear something and then you don't
remember where you saw or where you
heard it but it sticks with you and
eventually like but sometimes also some
people just think of the same jokes like
oh you don't meeting jokes I saw at the
same exact time about that quote from
Game of Thrones this week being in like
you're in like girls making it their
BIOS like when Cersei was like you want
a whole buy one you want a queen earn
her and she was also like right so it's
like ever there are so many jokes about
that like basic [ __ ] like taken out
of making it like their aim by oh you
know so people do think of the same
jokes like not every joke is so original
I agree I would be curious to hear the
examples you know I'm no fan or non fan
of Conan I have absolutely no horse in
this race but I could see both sides of
the coin here and I also could see them
doing it and see them not doing it right
but it's like comedians like and
especially once you like write jokes for
a living are so proud you know it's like
and there was going after like meme
accounts [ __ ] Jerry myself included like
just she had justice for comedians so I
have a hard time believing that they
would do this and if they do it sets
back patent also it's like entire life
yeah I mean I I need the
axé cuz I'm not just gonna make a
judgment here but I think it opens up a
larger conversation because this is
something lines come up a lot a lot of
comedians not even memes comedians have
been accused of stealing jokes because
you know some people do have the same
thought yeah but but you can always tell
like there is actually a video of like a
hundred times Amy Schumer copied a joke
and like sometimes it's word for it
she's like a sex machine where she calls
the Houdini or something like you know
someone else made that up you know yeah
that's what I was talking about I didn't
want to call her out because she cuz she
survived it I'm gonna bring it back up
again but we did make there was the
whole thing about Amy Schumer stealing
jokes and when I saw it I still didn't
know how to feel about it because it
really it to people kind of have the
same thought to people can have the same
thought like not and like there are some
jokes like in the industry actually went
to it like when I first are doing
stand-up like a um a comedy coach and
she's like a veteran like she has been
around forever she knows everyone and
they're like a couple jokes that are
like nobody owns them in stand-up so
it's like if you're doing stand-up and
you say that it's like where you guys
from and say you're from like Boise
Boise you know start yet so uh way from
Boise oh wow big night out for you
that's like um like a joke that nobody
owns you know so it's like maybe it's
that you know maybe I want I would like
to see the jokes please oh right like I
need I need receipts yeah me too
especially if they're so specific the
Washington Monument what are we making
jokes about okay so what's the comment
comedians name um Alex case Berg with a
K case Berg Washington Monument joke
it's better be funny yeah totally he's
probably so much money I don't know I
feel like actually this has come up a
lot and I feel like this I don't know if
this trial has a similar trial has ever
happened but I think it might you know
might change things cuz commenting in
the Internet's just a Wild West out the
guys seeking four hundred fifty thousand
dollars in damages that's crazy yeah and
that's not even unreasonable no oh
here's the joke a delta flight this week
took off from Cleveland to New York with
just two passengers they fought over
control of the armrest the entire flight
that's funny oh and then O'Brien said in
his monologue on Monday a delta flight
from Cleveland to New York took off with
just two passengers yeah
somehow they spent the whole flight
fighting over the armrest honestly
that's stolen for sure for sure
here's another one this is by the comic
Tom Brady said he wants to give his MVP
truck to the man who won the game for
the Patriots so enjoy that truck Pete
Carroll I guess that's the sports joke
we don't understand but O'Brien's joke
Tom Brady said he wants to give the
truck he was given at the Super Bowl MVP
- the guy who won the Super Bowl for the
Patriots
Sabrina's giving his truck to Seahawks
coach Pete Carroll ok so I guess that's
the coach and honestly that one doesn't
that one I could see two people coming
up yes yes yes coming up with I agree
okay here's the Caitlyn Jenner one I
agree never mind it includes generally
they might have a case here yeah the
first one for sure and I mean I keep
yeah I don't know it'll be interesante
that's I know for sure I love it things
that are into herself and you know I
even though no one's writing about this
trial I will be keeping up with it
you're gonna keep the tempo to go to San
Diego
however the case covers the case we'll
do a live stream right outside the
courthouse no one else will be in our
way because no one's covering okay we'll
be fighting over the armrest okay next
story shocking stuff everyone's worried
about me everyone want to check on me
because Jason why was she oh my god I
heard quote goodbye khal drogo I'm not
gonna lie like I'm so down for this I'm
dead like I don't love him because he
has a beard I mean look at you because
he's Jason Momoa dude he cut his hair no
damn even if he cut his hair he was seen
those old pictures of him did you have
an after show toe of him with his beard
off looks the same oh my god no he looks
so much better
he's so he and honestly I like if
someone showed me this picture of Jason
in my wedding I wouldn't notice that he
lost it yeah nobody's been so many
characters no he has a beard he doesn't
have a beard I don't even notice things
like that yeah me neither
like I accept of Zach no Zach could grow
a full beard
and by the time it was grown like I
wouldn't know that it happened you would
know cuz like when he kissed you it
would be like Crickley and gross lady
ready if he does like scruff sometimes
and that's when it's ticklish and
prickly but if it got beyond like Oh
unsanitary yeah and you know Jason Momoa
is the type of guy who just goes like
mudding for fun so there's [ __ ]
bacteria in there that is yet to be
discovered by science yeah hopefully
they'll test it who
filmed it was it vogue that filmed I saw
it on vogue take you really they did a
video oh I'm not sure
oh I just made that up then the Aquaman
actor drove fans into a frenzy on
Wednesday when he posted a video on
youtube of himself shaving his rugged
beard for the first time since 2012 true
to form Momoa isn't simply ridding
himself of the his most recognizable
look because of the end of Game of
Thrones like co-star Kit Harington did
that's what I want said the Hawaiian
actor probe the stunt as a way to
signify a quote change for the better
and encourage people to stop using
plastic bottles Wow quote just wouldn't
do this to bring awareness plastics are
killing our planet he said while taking
a razor to the scruffy beard in the
middle of a polluted desert in Jordan
where are you so glamorous it fans
immediately had mixed reactions about
his new look well done guys first you
destroyed the planet and now you
destroyed a shitty since the most
bearded no he looks great but on the
flip side I do need to talk to you about
Kit Harington because now I'm going back
watching games now he's Kate herring
right I'm watching it with her and I
have something extremely controversial
to say beard or no beard Kit Harington
is ugly I'm sorry I do not find him cute
and I think we're all just like glossing
over Torah okay we're glossing over Robb
Stark and I know like I'm I'm I just got
up to the part at the red wedding where
he chides like I'm still lamenting over
his death spoiler alert but I just like
I love him so much and now he's like
getting so famous and I follow this guy
is most influential I follow this
stylist
Mel Ottenberg and he's just always
posting premium content cuz he's always
posting around huh
but he's always just like working and
showing his work and he did the
interview magazine shoot with richard
madden who's Robb Stark and like I've
honestly never seen a hotter man in my
life like wow and now it's like
everything Jon Snow it's like honestly
you know and what is more unattractive
to me than Jon Snow Jon Snow on SNL
looking like a four year old in a
turtleneck with his big like white beard
I just I'm not into him looking like kid
Harrington yeah um okay well considering
I'm not someone who like really only
falls for looks
Rob's Taro's a [ __ ] dummy and for that
reason I am out nobody just went away
and his family
and like get revenge and get his sisters
back let's talk about Stannis wait okay
um I'm still in the part of Stannis
where he's about he okay they just sent
Gendry away and like he just found out
that I'm still with I'm like Stannis is
still alive for me but honestly I don't
remember what happens to satisfy me but
like first of all he was the true king
like he didn't aside from Daenerys and
no one knew that John's a Targaryen
dadís was the true king so he's the only
one who's not nuts he's a hero you know
he's a zag by the way Renly was out of
control just like just sided one day he
wanted to be king even though he had not
a single claim like four hundred people
had to die for him to [ __ ] be the
king yeah
no but Stannis like was the right player
and like I'm team Ned and even though
that was a bigger dummy than his son Ned
toe Stannis is his King too so Stannis
is the rightful heir he's King vibes
he's a war hero he's a D he's so brave
he's like and by the way these days I
have so much respect for the red woman
and because she was [ __ ] around about
everything the Lord of Light know she
got a few things wrong like definitely
they didn't need to burn Shuri in a lot
oh there was so sad some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
um but at the end of the day like she's
serving the Lord of Light as best as she
knows how she also is technically like a
very old woman without her necklace no I
don't know I'm so but like just I'm I
need to catch up when she's living at
the wall she takes off her magic
necklace oh yeah oh my god ninety years
old
spoiler alert but she talks like like an
actual geriatric so it makes sense yeah
and like come up with some new lines oh
my god at the new I totally ship
Melisandre and Sanus and I [ __ ] means
done it I feel really sad for statuses
wife like she's so sad no but like she's
so she so thirsty like she's so people
they look there she couldn't believe
less in the Lord of Light at any time
she gets a touch of status she's like
it's what the Lord of Light once so you
just thinking you're saying that cuz
what so and you heard Melisandre say you
know ya know she wants to be Melisandre
also Melisandre and Melisandre is
starting abusing this channel whatever
yeah it's confusing anyways so obviously
Khal Drogo is my number one but I'm just
trucking season five and out of the
people who are still alive now I'm gonna
Janice and also like time and Lannister
is definitely a monster but like right
all of the time okay right all the time
and lord beerus said he's like what's i
do five four he said he fights over um
but i was watching an episode and he
said honestly in this particular
scenario I'm on Tywin Lannister side
because he would be the best possible
leader yeah he would he would is a very
justified he in his own way ruled the
realm
since the Mad King was on the throne cuz
right hand of that back king so he's
keeping the realm move in for like 20
years here yeah also I just watched the
episode where Tilly Terry and kills
Tywin spoiler alert but and the last
thing he says before it Tyrion
puts the arrow the second arrow and his
art cuz he put some he shoots him once
and he can still talk and the last thing
he says before he gets clipped again is
you are no son of mine oh my oh but
you're 1,000% don't like thousand
percent right and then I went digging
because I was like okay which Targaryen
is that is Tywin's wife like rumored to
have slept with have slept with and cuz
like it is a very popular theory and I
don't even and I'm not gonna be [ __ ]
Conan O'Brien but I don't know that I
came up with it I might have been
trolling read it one night and so and I
wasn't looking for spoilers and I saw it
and then and now I see everything
through that lens okay Michael I like
you I don't want to know what you think
or like what what you found because
those theories on reddit are always
right okay no but I was reading just the
the histories of above the characters
like Joanna Lannister you know Theo
you're such a precious gem he just wants
to get in closer Lana
Lannister Tywin's why if I was just
reading like I don't know I wasn't like
what the book say about her so anyways
there is a there is a federal winery and
it checks out okay
and when the Prince of Dorne Oberyn like
is talking with Tyrion when he's in jail
and he was saying like how he was so
disappointed when he came to Castle Rock
as he was ready to meet like this
monster baby that everyone said like had
a tail drag him um and then turned out
he was just a normal baby you know what
I'm so torn because okay we're only see
we're only on Episode one there's five
more episodes and I can't tell if I want
to be like in it on reddit like reading
spoilers and like knowing the theories
because I didn't know that there was a
very popular theory that John was half
Targaryen half stark and then it checked
out to be true but when I found out I
was like so shipped to my core like
that's how you should watch a TV show
yeah so from
here on out I've decided I don't want to
know any more theories yeah I don't know
I go back and forth but just but it's in
terms of what's gonna happen at the end
I have no clue what that will be
shockworthy for me who is the Mad King
that will be shockworthy for me who's
gonna die who's gonna live you think
that the whole realm is going down I
think the whole realm is going down I
think that the White Walkers win and
then they sit on the throne right it
doesn't matter like it's like there was
all this fighting about who's gonna win
the throne and it truly doesn't [ __ ]
matter
yeah well then maybe it'll be oh my god
oh my god maybe they're gonna get all
political and be like you're all out of
here like living your lives to get every
little my new [ __ ] so important at the
end of the day like the earth the
environment the plastic maybe that's
what it is maybe the moa maybe the White
Walkers represent plastic maybe Jason
Momoa like is closer with george RR
martin right and then the realm is
symbolic of just like the environment
makes you think Theo Grace
Theo giri's okay fifth and final story
switching gears a little bit here cuz it
seemed
moderately important after 36 years the
font Helvetica is getting a much-needed
facelift do you know about how petaca of
course it's like one of the most
aesthetically pleasing bomb yeah
apparently there's a documentary about
it that I haven't seen but just the fact
that there's a documentary about a font
just tells me that it's a very important
font and you know if you would have
asked me what font I think there should
be a documentary on of course I would
say comics as a comic myself it might
say webdings and wingdings oh I wouldn't
say that I think like what do they mean
actually our brand our brand font is azo
sans uber very cool yeah check it out
everyone has an opinion about fonts but
Helvetica is long reigned over the
modern era it's used for brands galore
Panasonic Jeep American Airlines
Motorola 3m Toyota to name a few but in
recent years tech companies like IBM
Apple Netflix and Google have been
shifting to their custom Helvetica esque
but not quite fonts to deal with some of
its quirks rather Colette's Helvetica
die a slow death all 40,000 characters
in the world's most iconic typeface have
been revamped into a new font
wait for it called Helvetica now seems
like an in tune movie that's drama and
the font world I love a font that's
contemporary and keeps up with modern
trends you know and evolves right you
know quote this is not a revival this is
a restoration someone takes their jobs
so [ __ ] seriously writes monotype the
company which owns the light
sensing rights to Helvetica quote this
is a statement this is Helvetica now for
everyone everywhere for everything no I
would get their rocks off at this story
Oh
samwell tarly of course he misses oh it
feels so bad for people who don't watch
Game of Thrones no total it's gonna be
an annoying six weeks for you but like
honestly just like you think you're
better than everyone because you're
taking like a moral high ground like I
don't watch Game of Thrones and I
appreciate the resilience but like just
get involved okay you are missing out on
the greatest show of a generation like
when we all are long gone they will look
back at Game of Thrones and be like hey
maybe didn't they weren't all bad when I
was in high school it was the series
finale of Breaking Bad and the world was
not okay and I was a Breaking Bad in
there oh my god Wow like what and then
like a year later I started to watch it
I was like I wish I could just [ __ ]
wasn't such a little [ __ ] and leg was
on with everyone so I could have
experienced like oh my god spoiler alert
Walt dies you know I don't know I don't
watch it sorry like that's how I feel
about Mad Men I wish I watched it while
it was live so I could have known what
everyone else was thinking like I stand
Betty for [ __ ] ever and then like get
involved in the conversation and the
discourse right so don't come for me
anyways don't come saying news about how
petaca if any of you were in the font
sphere now you know what font was your
wedding invitation beats me screams use
cursive yeah what it was cursive with
some um some streets some blocks it was
some Helvetica it was curvy and it was
straight just like us yes just like nice
and straight and did your um did your
font on your imitation match your
wedding website uh no actually pretty
much cuz I did I did a nice cursive that
was a Zola font and it was quite
beautiful of course
I love his Olaf on I love his Ola free
font I love a Zilla period for all
things wedding like they make the most
treacherous time of your life like a bit
more bearable
because dole is the easiest way to plan
your wedding and register start with a
free wedding website and then build your
dream registry at zola they make
registering for newlywed life's so easy
to store has the widest selection of
gifts of all different price points
there's something for every guest to
love and all the guests love free
shipping free returns price matching and
way more to start your free running
website and also get
dollars off your registry go to zola
comm slash toast that's $50 off your
registry at zola comm slash toast 0l
a.com slash toast your favorite
breakfast food also one of my favorite
things that's all is that I was able to
register for like art gift cards
honeymoon fun more selections very end
chilling right as opposed to in addition
to pots and pans which you I need now
because I'm a master chef oh my god I
can't leave you got one was at your
third final class it was my third and
final class we've learned how to make
fish oh I don't know if I'll be making
fish in the home anytime soon but it's a
good thing to know and he taught us a
really quick and easy way to make salmon
like that actually I might do you just
like wrap it in the foil and put it
right all like the ingredients in yeah
that's very BuzzFeed oh and I was in
charge of making their out of chewy as I
told her on cuz I told everyone on
yesterday's show and they requires a lot
of chopping on veggies which is a skill
I needed to learn so I volunteered to
make the ratatouille you know not the
poached cod and in all of my chopping I
slashed my finger honestly the wound was
so deep and today is the first day that
it doesn't hurt to the touch ya know
Jeff is a really good about cleaning and
hydrogen peroxide it stopped pulsing I
was making schnitzel one time a couple
years ago and I sliced my finger so bad
and I had a scar for like for such a
long time thank God it went away blog if
you don't take care of it properly you
really should get stitches like that's
how why when you cut like a knife for
cooking it's really done Ben's dad as a
chef he's the craziest fingers we have
to look at his fingers my finger is so
small that I'm sorry like I can hit bone
so quickly yep there's not much to
protect that bone much too good for
children much too good for knives
yes so you got to be careful yeah but
I'm really I think I'm gonna make some
of my world renowned grilled russet we
grew our own Sookie know because the
ratatouille was cool and it was it was
exciting to learn how to make
ratatouille I learned how to peel a
tomato
harder than you think but in terms of
taste I just wanted to eat those golden
zucchini and eggplant so that I think
when I make that for the seder tomorrow
and like show everyone my new skills are
we making is it a potluck Seder he weeks
and $300 later
is it a potluck Seder no but I just
thought you know everyone okay no cuz it
made it seem like I had to bring
something everyone round to see what
I've been working on truly okay
well let's wrap up the show with a few
things
one reminder that I still need a couple
stagecoach passes so like please hit me
up email me gme whatever some artist
passes please - we're back tomorrow back
tomorrow regular time scheduled
programming thank you for bearing with
us yes and please be vocal what do you
like what don't you like - you like a
later showed you like a earlier showed
you prefer gas hose with a video or just
a podcast with me and Jackie let us know
I've enjoyed this Late Show but I feel
like once I get up from the chair I'm
gonna be so turned around like what
somebody that's a good day so they can't
think need to go have lunch but it's 5
o'clock yeah I'm starving yeah I have
errands to run I have a nephew to
babysit we have we have so much to do so
much to do
including following me on Instagram I
track EO problems and you know what I'm
actually like done saying they say my
goals because like I literally made the
smallest goal which is like get
followers from Coachella and like I
literally I didn't get any I didn't lose
any like a stagnant it was like the Lord
of Light was like [ __ ] you and your [ __ ]
goals piss off thank you guys so much
for watching the Millenial morning show
the morning shows we go live Monday
through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time
EQ Julie on YouTube and we're also
available as a podcast anywhere podcast
can be listened to - make sure to
subscribe to us on iTunes Spotify
wherever else you can find a podcast and
tomorrow we will recap Vanderpump rules
Beverly Hills in New York because I have
not watched any of them because Game of
Thrones is better than any garbage on TV
but tonight I will satisfy the thrones
because I'm in between seasons and we
will catch up well recap everything so
SIA mañana bye guys
you